so now Pascal Vaughn cotton is going to
give us a talk about depth care chatbot
generating answers to customers using a
rate approach of their learning and
natural language processing please give
him a warm applause
[Applause]
computer vision sorry okay a lot of
companies are experimenting with these
new technologies computer vision machine
learning and yeah personally I really
enjoy these kind of human machine
interaction kind of new technologies so
I don't know who is familiar with the
Gartner hype cycle a lot of innovation
managers are it's how they decide what
to try next
things like augmented reality virtual
reality and and well this is where you
can find me at the red arrows I
experimented with a lot of things I
really like to do so I also contribute
to the projects on github so I feel free
to check it out things like using Wi-Fi
signals in your laptop to have your
machine understand where this like when
you look at your webcam and move your
eyes that the mouse is also following it
it's not really dong solo but it's a fun
experiment I've used some machine
intelligence for for web crawling and a
neuro complete it's like a neural
network that learns to autocomplete
neural network code I will give a talk
about it in two weeks in Moscow and well
finally another fun project that I'm
doing in my spare time is is deep care
and I should say it doesn't actually
have to do anything with care really but
it's more about web care so that's a bit
of a difference so when people reply on
on on Twitter than there are actually
companies that are giving reaching out
story so it's more about web care so we
are now first like what is said but I
don't know how many people know it
it's that this idea that for example in
a facebook messenger if you want to book
a flight you could go to to a website to
book a flight but is also possible to to
write some like Skyscanner boat or
i said i want to book a vacation and
says okay where do you want to go or
maybe you can say like a whole sentence
and to interpret it correctly but so i
mean in business it said like first web
then phone apps came along and now it's
all about it's going to be me people
don't really want to install a lot of
apps so it's going to be a set built in
facebook messenger for example okay this
is another example so I'm interested in
like natural language and like trying to
understand what people are saying in
Texas also of what we're doing it as
Isis a lot with with like Ana map
analysis on textual data but what you
can actually see with most Jade boxes
that's really like scripted and like
what people are actually saying is it
doesn't really need a lot of like
language analysis like saying anywhere
along and that's more like a more like a
lookup yeah so um I like to complicate
it a bit so yeah those kind of Ted bots
are more like they're taking the
initiative it's kind of like the menu
that you have on when you are calling
and press one to to do something right
but so I wanted to do more something
like reactive with deep there
yes so for me it's like a fun experiment
to see something like what about
reactive some people wrote some text and
like let's try to generate an answer for
it
okay so I've I select the data sorry for
deep learning it's important to have a
lot of data and I thought okay where can
I find some interesting data so in the
end I ended up with with AT&T the phone
provider in the States and I so they
have 1.3 million tweets on their on
their account so I thought it will be
interesting to do something with that
data so I collected 100,000 examples
through Twitter where someone was saying
one thing like I don't know I want the
iPhone and then some employee of AT&T
replied to it and after doing some
analysis on it I was trying to look for
like a cluster to start at like not to
try to solve the whole thing but to
start with a cluster and interesting
cluster I found was they attempt like
apparently they're doing a lot of social
selling so people are writing on Twitter
I want the new iPhone and then there's
AT&T who's replying to that like ok
maybe you want to click on this link so
that's the interesting cluster so what
is the problem for companies is AT&T
receives three thousand tweets every day
and so they need a lot of people to
answer these tweets probably they have a
lot of other channels as well and so
corporations are looking for automated
solutions but yeah it's really it's
really complicated problem because
someone might say something about an
iPhone but just want some information
about an iPhone as someone to complain
about an iPhone and someone says like
can you cancel my iPhone contract well
there's a lot of it's a complicated task
but also maybe sometimes a bot needs to
detect when a student reply for example
when there's a like somebody's upset or
something maybe don't want to have both
answer to that
I thought okay let's try to do something
like a bit more innocent
so like duties social selling tasks
instead of looking at these sensitive
problems so my goal was like without
business constraints like let's just
want to work on a fun problem and let's
see if we can make a boat that can reply
yeah so it's a kind of a spoiler already
but I ride for us to do it with deep
learning and there's some were some
downsides that I thought okay you know
what let's just try a little bit of NOP
as well so a natural language processing
Toya and I kind of do a two-stage model
first like natural language processing
and then deep deep learning I'm not
saying that it's really a good idea I
think that in the end you will try to do
it all in one model but it forces the
experiment okay so now let's try I made
a little app around it because for me
that's fun to do as well try to see if I
can get that to appear
okay well so just for show that you can
choose a username so this is kind of
that just an interface it's it's not
real so you can type and they spot to
answer but it's not anything is
happening with my username or nothing is
being written to Twitter but you could
actually imagine that this this could
could happen so um so this guy's
enhancer or another example maybe
let's hope it works and not someone
killed it but that looks to be the case
luckily I have the slides with some
examples anyway what I still can show
you here is find a mouse it's like I
just did some days ago just like okay
insert the query like the iPhone or
something on that on Twitter and then
you got some recent tweets and how the
bot would reply to it so yeah it's
pretty fun to see what happens sometimes
it goes wrong sometimes it's quite nice
like I don't know
and so the interesting thing is that so
they're generated answers if you change
the comma then the output will be
completely different again that's
usually something that companies don't
like right they want the predictability
data to change the comma which you would
think is no doesn't have any meaning but
it still changes the output I don't know
what I'm looking for but yeah so let's
go back to the presentation feel free to
try it maybe afterwards I can put it
back online
so here's some examples so what's
interesting is that you can see that the
well the employee or the both replies it
likes and I hurt you and so it's like
quite fun and playful of course based on
the actual data so something like a
detects that there's mention of to not
mention of two devices and so it says
something about you have radios from
both I'm not I don't think that's
actually really what about knows but
yeah sister
deck size but them and this Erica CD a
not be kind of when you say I want to
see a movie then it doesn't start
generating answers right because that's
a problem with a lot of deep learning
tasks that you do if you give really
nonsense to it you are going to get
really a lot of notice and that's
something that companies will not accept
know so I was kind of working with an
Opie on like I want an iPhone but when
you say I want to sell an iPhone and
again you have to make sure that it's
not thinking interpreted in s like oh
you want to sell an iPhone here we can
give you an iPhone so yeah another fun
one I want the case for my iPhone 6
we've got you covered
like right fun fun stuff okay so yeah
problem I see problem is with deep
learning and that's like when you say
stop my Samsung contract then if a boss
says okay I've stopped your iPhone
contract actually there's not that much
error in there right they just got the
phone wrong but yeah that could have a
big big consequence when when it
suddenly starts cancelling the wrong
contract okay so now I wanted to talk a
bit about what I implemented and there's
no code but yeah
so that this is kind of I used a lot of
pre-processing because I think it will
help the strength of your deep learning
and you are like any model it helps when
you do like pre-processing but I think
you should focus on like the things that
can be used in other projects or like
like keep its general generic so you can
really use it and well also spend a lot
of time on the domain-specific so in
this case understanding iPhone is in the
text is really important if you want
building something around that so make
sure that you can correctly recognize
that otherwise you get things like a
model things like iPhone 5 and in the
answer there's like other iPhone 6 but
there's no guarantee that you that the
thing there's no guarantee that what is
in the question will be correct in the
answer with with deep learning so ok so
then we have the first base one kind of
suit the bots answer or not and Phase
two generating a unique answer and
afterwards it will post processing so
like when you see my in the answers you
see my username that's something like
you work with the variable called
username right
and then at the moment that you're
writing it from Twitter you get
someone's names or you could use that
name to a personal address someone okay
so if we take this example it's actually
not one of the training data but you can
imagine it is it would be seen like this
after the pre-processing so like the
names between no name so I can we know
user names in whenever when you get a
through the Twitter API so whenever you
see these names that's kind of
pre-processing or you see the Twitter
handle you can replace it with a token
name and then later kind of try to do
that back and it's interesting because
in in I think that they are trying to
take this kind of like using these
context
three key things they are trying to
build models for doing that in one model
with the neural network which are so
challenging thing and I thought you know
this is just fun to see how far can we
get by just trying to hack something
together now so you see all the things
like offer link one year a month the
initials and web care link so yeah
mention the name the there's often
things like employee names and the
availability of them there's a lot of
tags and a lot of links and I
experimented a bit with links because
yeah there's a directive of course a lot
of links but maybe you're interested in
like an offer link right so maybe you
just want to give a latest offer and
that should come from some other API
want to give the latest offer so you
kind of want to normalize links I think
at first I just did links later I
changed it a bit to like goodbye link or
like this is or a team and this is like
an offer em and emoticons is nice to
treat so well so you can use them as
your model so then I did also some like
specific or domain specific
pre-processing like you have your
incentive brand name really well
competitors maybe and products but the
more time you have for your project the
more I think it will be benefiting you
if you try to generalize a bit though of
course are a lot of purist and
especially academics that don't do any
kind of pre-processing where there's
tokens with question marks attached to a
token and well I just think it's it kind
of help right you don't want to or I
don't want to have that in the back of
my mind that that could be making your
model worse so as I do the
pre-processing to generalize to try to
hope to generalize and and I only want
to pre-process things that I think maybe
I can reuse that and the domain specific
things
in this case only product that you can
imagine more so then we come to the
restricting the answering like one can
it answer or not and I did that it NOP
so I don't know how many yeah there are
some people that very interested in it
you are kind of the old old oldest way
to do natural language processing is
just taking words and just seeing them
as a unique token right you have the
word hello that gets a zero the next
word I that's a one I don't yeah
something like that
it's each individual word having a
unique number but yeah I thought like
let's try to use something more
complicated because I don't think you
can easily work with just that so yeah
well benefit of an obvious like it
allows from generalization because when
you have like one or once then that's
just simply different numbers like how
that's being feature iced so there's no
general ation but if you use a lemma so
then cats because cats are like stemming
of verbs wants to want then kind of you
get some kind of generalization yeah so
little problem is that you're depending
on a language model getting that right
also with part of speech and so I show
here an example of a dependency tree
it's using Spacey and what you can see
here is like that the sentence I want an
iPhone is being put in like a dependency
tree I guess it's better to read about
it and me trying to explain enough for
long time but you can kind of get yeah
you can get more out of language so in
this case we want this verb and it's on
the root level you have I which subject
your iPhone which is an object and well
I use this kind of information for the
hoodie for restricting when you should
answer or not if you're doing a naive
thing like this so you're using these
features and you're just
okay we're going to use all these lemma
type features part of speech features
dependency tree features you end up with
really like I mean if you just use words
is a lot but it will explode so I
thought maybe let's try some rules there
but the grading rules can be
time-consuming benefit of doing using
the IOP in this case it's very
transparent when you see something like
when it's something slips by the model
makes a mistake it's unit up answer it
it's still very transparent to why it's
why it went wrong hmm so the rule rules
can actually give guarantees deep
learning can't okay so I use space it's
a very great library in my opinion for
natural language processing they are
also including a lot of the nice thing I
think they also are going to include
neural networks in there well in my case
I build the rules
using part of speech lemma and negation
and yeah so it's a bit going to be
technical but and small but yeah so the
simplification I made this you need the
words want or need as a verb in your
sentence like then only we're going to
use this you want to act the product or
iPhone as a nearby child of this like
root so underneath in the tree you don't
want to have any like negation so when
you say I don't want an iPhone you don't
want it to be wrongly interpreted so it
I thought it's a fun way at least to do
this not because you don't often see it
being used in a lot of models right
especially the simple models they don't
use any information really correctly
with word not so if you say I don't want
to fly to Spain and it says great the
great that you're flying to Spain right
so it's actually a tricky thing and I
wanted to solve it using the negation in
the part of speech and another
restriction I have is that the subject
is I in this case so you can not my
sister my sister once
I found that it doesn't work at this
moment but of course you can expand on
these rules so this is the case that we
had I want the case from - six and when
we when we are making the dependency
tree you can see that it looks like this
so you have little check marks for these
kind of parts of the rules that are
working there more examples
I know if readable pieces but yeah so
when you say I want the Samsung Galaxy
its units I mean that's the restriction
I put myself only selling iPhones so
then it shouldn't suggest something or
you say I do not want an iPhone it also
should not make a suggestion and when
you say I do not want an iPhone but I
want the Samsung Galaxy then it's again
not iPhone so it shouldn't react and the
last one is like I do not want the
Samsung Galaxy but an iPhone so and the
nice thing is that it still works but so
this is a rule based just for should it
answer or not and then we go to the to
the generative parts are the right so
now the model so I applied all these
rules also in preparation of training
the the generative model so we are I had
a hundred thousand tweets and after
using these kind of rules preparation I
was still left with fifteen thousand
samples it is not super big but still
quite nice for because it's a much
smaller domain and trying to solve like
so so the training of the models is also
using this pre-processing step which
means that after you get some new input
your first saying is it is it ok or not
according to the rules yes it's okay
okay then we can generate an answer
okay so i used google sec two sec i
don't know who knows it it's about it's
about mapping sequences of words or
numbers to another sequence of words or
numbers it's used in machine translation
or text summarization conversation
modeling image captioning according to
google and well i think a lot of people
are experimenting with it in even more
ways that one of the examples is the
chinese sentence to english sentence
example and the goal is of course given
the training examples of a lot of
chinese and english sequences which do
not have to be the same length to to
learn a good model moja so it can also
be used to create a chatbot it's not
exactly like transfer machine
translation but yeah you can say
something like given this question this
answer should be there and then the
model can work with that also fun to
know is that they announce that they are
probably using something like this in
Google Translate so this is their
explanation of it I survived yeah for me
it's not the best word to explain it
with this one so I found this example
and I encourage you to read this link so
we have sequence of word sequence of
answers and so first step is is the
words in two numbers then then you have
encoder so it's psycho psycho long
short-term memory model you're trying to
learn from like when you see the to give
an example I want to I would like to eat
could be an example like then on the top
rights you have have to learn these
transitions from I would too
like to eat as a whole in the end you
have some some state which is fixed
let's say thirty two variables at the
end and so you so you're learning this
based on these words I'm sorry for this
explanation but and but the thing is so
after you do this encoding stage you end
up with fixed size and then so when you
are doing the decoding so you're trying
to like in another language or then it
would go over it so in another language
then I would like to eat but it's
normally if you have a Markov model you
have something like okay what is the
chance that's given I would the word is
like and if that's the highest chance
then you could use that but in the
example of I would like to eat maybe if
that's the most current way then then it
will not change to something else but if
in the encoding so in your question
there's the word eat in another language
or right or in clue of iPhone then this
information is available when you're
trying to learn this decoding so instead
of I would like to eat it can then do
something that's less popular choice I
would like to drink because it's because
it's available in this encoding stage so
it's about learning the encoding and the
decoding yeah I would encourage you to
read the book yeah so I use tensorflow
for this and more specifically the the
yeah you can I would if you want to see
some code then go to this repository you
can easily get started yourself with
that sorry these are my network settings
I experimented I started with really
small models so the downside is that you
can capture a lot less and I started to
but I wanted to see if it kind of works
with like smaller settings and then
slowly build it out I think due to the
time is not really interesting to
discuss what these parameters exactly
are
or quickly maybe the best now okay this
is something you can read easily online
you can also see the tensor board so
that's where you can monitor the loss I
just yeah it's Australian for 24 hours
on my CPU so if you have a TV that's
probably three hours and if you do it in
India yeah if you're much more serious
about it you can do much more larger
models and maybe you don't have to stick
to first this smaller domain okay so my
conclusions like God still makes small
grammar mistakes or things that you find
out but in my opinion it's quite fun at
least to see what it comes up with and
it still makes mistakes in logic but I
try to kind of minimize that by this
approach it's not optimal because it's
too modest but it was from a very fun
experiment and I don't know if you heard
about this opening I model that was
training on the movie ratings and then
they found out it understood sentiment
well my this model also contains a bit
of sentiment as a bit of a joke I'm
sorry that was my presentation
[Applause]
any question
question about like the hyper parameter
to choose that there's a embedding what
why do you choose like hundred and
twenty-eight and what's the relation
with the like in bernalillo for example
so my hyper parameter search was very
simple I started with small and I double
everything when I think like okay it's
still okay sorry I just increased
everything it's not really like I didn't
spend a lot of time on on hyper
parameters because I found that it
worked quite well so in the original
repository they're using 32 and I
thought that it gave a little bit of
phew I thought that they didn't have
couldn't really represent a lot so I
then then for me to come work okay let's
just higher the values of embedding so
that can contain more intricacies
similarly with the amount of layers
well amount of units and I stick to two
layers because well that's kind of what
a lot of people are using right and when
I changed it to three for a farm I could
do quite a bit longer to Train it so I
thought okay let's just a quick so as
Noah there's no science from my side
behind the kind of choices it's a more
questions
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]